اوضاع صعبه للغايه مع استمرار المنخفض
الجوي وايضا هطول الامطار والرياح الشديده
التي تضرب المنطقه هنا تحديدا في مدينه
رفح التي يتواجد بها اكثر من مليون و500
ال نازح فلسطيني اجبرتهم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على ترك منازلهم والتوجه الى
مدينه رفح يعيش الناس في هذه المنطقه
اوضاع صعبه يحاولون استصلاح ما يمكن
استصلاحه في الخيام التي تسربت اليها مياه
الامطار في ساعات الصباح الباكر وايضا
طيله
ساعات الليل ما ادى الى خراب في حاجياتهم
ومقتنياتهم في هذه الخيام بالاضافه الى
البرد الشديد الذي يعاني منه الاطفال
وكبار السن واصحاب الامراض المزمنه نتيجه
عدم توفر وسائل تدفه او حتى الا الاغطيه
اللازمه والملابس الشتويه للاطفال والنساء
وايضا كبار السن في هذه المنطقه
يتواجد اكثر من 10000 نازح في هذا المخيم
لوحده الذي نتواجد به والوضع هو وضع صعب
يشتكون من قله الدعم المقدم لهم من عدم
توفر خيام مناسبه خاصه مع الاجواء الماطره
والمنخفض الذي يضرب المنطقه منذ عده ايام
المطر نزلت علينا برحر ماتنا وفراشه يما
ايش هالحياه يما هذه هذه مش حياه يما يا ب
موتونا يا ب روحو على الدار واحده من
الاني ياما مش هيك ياما هيك هيك الحياه
ياما الميه كله شحت مش حتهم ياما ونغطي
خرج اهمنا على البلاط يما لا فرشه ما في
عنت بخته ما في عنت هات حياه يما س ابنا
ضونا وسيبنا حالنا وجانا للبدله يما مين
بيرضى يما اقل ما يمكن ان نوصف مشهد
ماساوي وكارثي للغايه في ظل عدم توفر ادنى
المقومات التي تساعدهم
على البقاء على قيد الحياه وايضا مواجهه
الظروف المعيشيه الصعبه والاحوال الجويه
العاصفه والما طره التي تضرب مدينه رفح
جنوبي قطاع عزه هذه المدينه
الحدوديه التي لا تتوفر فيها ادنى
المقومات الاساسيه لاستقبال هذه الاعداد
الكبيره والهائل في ظل عجز المنظمات
الاغاثي الدوليه او حتى المحليه عن تقديم
المساعدات امام هذه الاعداد الكبيره وايضا
عدم تدفق مساعدات كافيه لهذه الاعداد
الكبيره التي تقطن مدينه
رفح